THANKS FOR SHARING THAT WITH US
AS ALWAYS, THANK YOU.
WHILE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR
SEARCHS FOR TRUTH AND JUSTICE,
THE DEMOCRATS ON CAPITOL HILL
BUSY WASTING YOUR TIME, OTHER
PEOPLE'S MONEY, STILL ADVANCING
A HOAX, STILL ADVANCING LIES AND
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
JERRY NADLER IS DEMANDING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL REVEAL GRAND
JURY INFORMATION IN THE MUELLER
REPORT.
NADLER ACTUALLY WANTS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE UNITED
STATES TO COMMIT A CRIME OR HE'S
GOING TO BE HANDCUFFED BY THE
SERGEANT OF ARMS.
REALLY?
AS LAW PROFESSOR JONATHAN TURLEY
POINTED OUT, IT IS NADLER WHO IS
IN FOR A WORLD OF HURT IF HE
CONTINUES THIS.
WATCH THIS.
>> I BELIEVE THAT THE CONTEMPT
ACTION OF THIS COMMITTEE WAS
UNFOUNDED, BUT I ALSO BELIEVE
FIT GOES A FEDERAL COURT THIS IS
ANOTHER AREA WHERE I THINK THAT
THIS COMMITTEE COULD LOSE.
WHEN SENATORS ASK ME WHY WON'T
HE COMMIT TO RELEASING THE FULL
UNREDACTED REPORT.
I SAID THAT WOULD BE A CRIME.
YOU ARE HEADING INTO A WORLD OF
HURT IF YOU GO TO THE D.C.
CIRCUIT AND ARGUE THAT YOU COULD
ORDER BARR, THAT BARR COULD
UNILATERALLY RELEASE THE
INFORMATION.
>> Sean: THE FISHING EXPEB DIGS
IS GOING NOWHERE.
IN AN EFFORT TO BE TRANSPARENT,
BARR HAS EXPANDED ACCESS TO MOST
UNREDACTED, THE MOST UNREDACTED
VERSION OF THE MUELLER REPORT.
SO THAT DEMOCRATS, IF THEY JUST
TAKE THE TIME, THEY CAN SEE
ALMOST ALL OF IT.
NO WORD BY THE WAY IF ANY
DEMOCRATS WILL BOTHER TO TAKE
THE TIME TO LOOK.
ONE SEN TENLS AND SEVEN PARTIAL
SENTENCES REMOVED -- SENTENCE
AND SEVEN PAR, SENTENCESES
REMOVED.
BARR'S LEGITIMATE INVESTIGATION
INTO THE DEEP STATE IS WELL
UNDERWAY.
SO IS THE HOROWITZ PROBE INTO
FISA ABUSE AND THE HOOVER REPORT
INVESTIGATING LEAKING.
WE LEARNED ABOUT THE JOHN DORUM
INVESTIGATION INTO THE ORIGINS
OF THE RUSSIA PROBE.
THE ONCE POWERFUL MEMBERS OF
THIS DEEP STATE WE'VE BEEN
EXPOSING FOR TWO YEARS TONIGHT
RUNNING SCARED AND THEY'RE NOW
TURNING ON EACH OTHER.
AS WE REPORTED LAST NIGHT, LISA
PAIGE, PETER STRZOK, PUTTING THE
BLAME RIGHT ON THEN-ATTORNEY
GENERAL LORETTA LYNCH.
COMEY IS TRASHING STRZOK AND
PAIGE ON NATIONAL TV.
ROD ROSENSTEIN TRASHED BY JAMES
COMEY.
HE'S TRASHING BACK.
THEY'RE BOTH ATTACKING EACH
OTHER'S CHARACTER.
THEN THERE'S BRENNON AND COMEY,
BLAMING EACH OTHER FOR PROMOTING
AND PUSHING THE DIRTY CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN
DOSSIER.
AND COMEY'S GENERAL COUNSEL,
JAMES BAKER, REVEALED HE WAS,
QUOTE, QUITE WORRIED THAT HIS
BOSS, DIRECTOR COMEY OF THE FBI,
WAS LITERALLY BLACKMAILING
DONALD TRUMP WITH HILLARY'S
DIRTY RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
YOU COULDN'T PUT THIS IN A SPY
NOVEL BUT IT'S TRUE.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> THE HOOVER DAYS,
INVESTIGATION OF MARTIN LUTHER
KING JR., WHAT WAS DONE THERE, I
DON'T KNOW, WHAT THE WORD IS,
THE BLACKMAILING OF DR. MARTIN
LUTHER KING.
SO, YEAH, WE WERE QUITE WORRIED
ABOUT THAT, QUITE WORRIED HOW IT
WOULD COME OFF.
WE WANTED TO TRY AND MAKE SURE
TO CONVEY TO THE PRESIDENT-ELECT
IN A'S WHAT WE WERE NOT DOING.
SIR, WE HAVE THIS INFORMATION,
IT CAME TO US IN A PARTICULAR
WAY, THE PRESS HAS IT, IT'S
ABOUT TO COME OUT, YOU SHOULD BE
ALERTED TO THAT FACT.
WE DON'T WANT TO PROCEED ON THIS
BASIS WITHOUT YOU BEING AWARE OF
THOSE FACTS.
WE WERE WORRIED ABOUT THE HOOVER
ANALOGIES AND DETERMINED NOT TO
HAVE SUCH A DISASTER HAPPEN ON
OUR WATCH.
>> Sean: WE'VE WARNED JIMBO,
IT'S NOT A GOOD LOOK WHEN YOUR
OWN GENERAL COUNSEL IS COMPARING
YOU TO J. EDGAR HOOVER.
OF COURSE THE FBI CHIEF WHO WAS
FAMOUS FOR ABUSING POWER, SPYING
ON AMERICANS, AND, YES,
BLACKMAILING HIS POLITICAL
ADVERSARIES.
WHILE BAKER EXPRESSED CONCERN
OVER HOW COMEY USED THE DOSSIER
HE CLAIMED THAT THE FBI TOOK THE
DOSSIER SERIOUSLY.
BUT NOT LITERALLY.
REALLY?
WAS THAT WAS THE BULK OF THE
INFORMATION IN THE FISA
APPLICATIONS.
SOUNDS LIKE THEY TOOK IT
LITERALLY.
TYKE TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE INFORMATION CAME IN AND
THERE WAS A LOT OF DETAIL WITH
RESPECT TO A LOT OF DIFFERENT
TYPES OF ACTIVITIES THAT WERE
ALLEGEDLY GOING ON.
AND SO, I GELS THE WAY I HAVE
PHRASED IT, WE TOOK IT
SERIOUSLY, WE DIDN'T NECESSARILY
TAKE IT LITERALLY THAT, WAS
LITERALLY TRUE IN EVERY RESPECT.
BUT IT WAS SOMETHING THAT WE
WERE OBLIGATED TO DEAL WITH AND
OBLIGATED TO ASSESS, GIVEN WHAT
WE UNDERSTOOD, WHAT I UNDERSTOOD
TO BE THE SOURCE OF THE
INFORMATION, CHRISTOPHER STEELE
AT THAT POINT IN TIME.
WE WERE OBLIGATED TO TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY AND LOOK AT IT, TRY TO
FIGURE OUT WHETHER IT WAS TRUE
OR NOT.
>> Sean: HOLD ON A SECOND.
IF YOU DIDN'T TAKE THE HILLARY
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN
DOSSIER SERIOUSLY OR LITERALLY,
WHY DID JAMES COMEY IN OCTOBER
OF 2016 SWEAR, IT SAYS AT THE
TOP OF THE FISA APPLICATION,
VERIFIED.
WHY DID HE SWEAR THAT THE
CONTENTS WERE TRUE AND ACCURATE
IN THE FIRST FISA REQUEST?
WHY WAS THAT REQUEST MARKED
VERIFIED AT THE VERY TOP?
DID JAMES COMEY LIE THEN OR DID
HE LIE IN JANUARY OF 2017 WHEN
HE SAID TO THEN PRESIDENT-ELECT
TRUMP, IT'S SALACIOUS BUT NOT
VERIFIED.
HE IS AT THE CENTER WHAT WAS A
MULTI YEAR EFFORT BY THE MOST
POWERFUL UNELECTED BUREAUCRATS
CLEARLY FIRST TO RICK AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THEIR
FAVORITE CANDIDATE WHEN THE
EVIDENCE WAS OVERWHELMING AND
INCONTROVERTIBLE.
THE ESPIONAGE ACT, OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE, THE INTENT WAS CLEAR
DESTROY THE EVIDENCE, THAT'S WHY
HILLARY CLINTON DELETED 30,000
E-MAILS, YOU USE BLEACH BIT, YOU
HAVE AN AID BURNT UP YOUR
DEVICES AND REMOVE ALL OF THE
SIM CARDS.
THAT WOULD BE INTENT.
SOMETHING THEY TRIED TO PIN ON
DONALD TRUMP WHEN THERE WAS NO